Michael Anton is a former senior
national security official in the Trump
administration a lecturer at Hillsdale
College and probably the first person in
this generation to raise the question of
whether birthright citizenship is indeed
constitutional thank you very much
Michael Anthony you wrote this piece
that's I think began this current
conversation this past July and people
were stunned to find out that this was
not a settled matter most people believe
this is etched on the bottom of the
Statute of Liberty but it's not right
and I do want to give credit where
credit's due to people that I learned
these arguments from John Eastman yes a
constitutional scholar and lawyer
litigator he litigates constitutional
questions and edward earl herbs a
student of the American Founding in the
Civil War era who's done the really the
scholarly work on this I learned this
argument from them they're two of my
teachers but it's true that you know it
had kind of gone dormant for a while so
everyone believes that we have a
constitutional mandate to allow the
children of illegal aliens become
citizens and they base that belief on a
misreading of the very first sentence of
the 14th amendment which says all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States are citizens they leave
out the part of the middle subject to
the jurisdiction thereof they either
leave it out or they say subjects of the
jurisdiction just means you have to obey
the law well everybody has to obey the
law if you're a tourist coming from
England or Canada or anywhere you have
to obey US law while you're in the
United States that doesn't make your
children a citizen or US citizen subject
to the jurisdiction meant something
specific to the people who wrote the
amendment we know this because they said
it you read the debates over the
amendment they said it means that you
don't know allegiance to any foreign
power to anyone else you're subject to
the complete jurisdiction in the United
States these are not a citizen of
another country so it clearly doesn't
apply to people who aren't citizens or
who are born to people who aren't
citizens who are subject to the
jurisdiction of another country the
Constitution is clear on that point
there's no statute that says otherwise
but decades ago the executive branch
agencies of the federal government just
decided to apply this principle as if
well we owe everyone birthright
citizenship now why do they do that
why do bureaucracies typically in our
country anyway typically act without
Authority usually it's to serve the
interests of liberalism when the
administrative state starts doing
something that it's not authorized to do
and
no one has ever told it to do you can
bet it's not doing so for conservative
reasons or for reasons that benefit
American citizens it's doing so for
reasons that benefit liberalism and
that's what happened in this case so
you're hearing the argument now from the
usual course of dumb people that this
like everything that they don't like is
racist
correct me if I'm wrong but the purpose
of this amendment was to enfranchise
people who had been in South African
Americans who've been enslaved
absolutely and so in what sense would
this does that argument even make sense
no and I want to take it seriously as
you say though it's the racist it's just
a cudgel with which to beat up people
whose arguments you don't like so the
Thirteenth Amendment free diverse llave
you've had a controversy at the time
where some states were saying ok you can
free the slaves but we have the power to
make them citizens and we're not going
to do it so the Congress passed the
Civil Rights Act of 1866 the same
Congress same year that drafted this
amendment that was vetoed by President
Johnson the veto was overridden so you
get two-thirds of both houses saying
free black slaves they are citizens and
that also says not subject to any
foreign power well then some of the
southern states came back with okay well
1857 the Supreme Court ruled in Dred
Scott that no black person even a free
black person could ever be a citizen of
the United States
so the reconstruction Congress said okay
then we're gonna put this in the
Constitution we're not gonna let you get
away with we're going to make this
undeniable that every freed slave and
their descendants are citizens so an
amendment designed to enfranchise
african-americans born here been here
400 years 500 years is now being used by
Chinese nationals and Russians to
Russians flying into Guam or Los Angeles
to have children here that would be not
the original intent I think it's
absolutely not I mean one of the things
that I find incredible and amusing sadly
the so though is well you know that
Russia hysteria of our time Russia is
supposed to be the biggest enemy of the
United States has right now more
dangerous enemy than in the Cold War you
know we're all supposed to be almost on
a war footing with Rush yes and the
president is criticized for saying maybe
we should cool it a little bit and turn
them to heat down however we can't
question the practice of Russian women
flying to my aunt
and having their babies to get us
birthday of course so this supposed
enemy of ours
it's a sacrosanct principle to allow
them to abuse our system by giving
citizenship to their children who you
know are born here spend a couple of
days and then go back to Moscow
so the real principle that undergirds it
is hurting ourselves were required to
hurting ourselves and of course hurting
the president the story is all about
hurting about America masochism being
the operating impulse of the left it's
bizarre Michael Anton who kicked this
off thank you very much thank you for
having me